[Musique]
le sénat représente les collectivités
territoriales de la république ils
représentent les mères c'est dizaines de
milliers d les locaux qui finalement
sont au plus proche de nos concitoyens
qui sont là pour répondre à leurs
attentes et à leurs questions
quotidiennes depuis 2015 le président
gérard larcher
onovo taille au président du groupe et
le président philippe badin commission
des lois ayant souhaité que le sénat s
intéresse à toutes ces évolutions
institutionnelles à toutes ces loi de
réforme territoriale que nous puissions
finalement être au contact permanent de
celles et ceux qui sont les garants les
sentinelles de notre démocratie locale
c'est ce que nous avons fait en allant à
leur rencontre sur l'ensemble des
départements de france
[Musique]
on a constaté beaucoup de difficultés
aujourd'hui pour exercer le monde à des
locales nous avons subi avec un
conseiller municipal une agression
physique musclé notre rôle est de
défendre les intérêts de la commune de
ses administrés mais pas forcément de se
défendre soi même la loi engagement
proximité a intégré donc cette
problématique notamment sur
l'élargissement du périmètre de
l'assurance obligatoire et l'extension
de l'assistance financière de l'état aux
communes de moins de 3500 habitants
c'est vraiment une avancée significatif
[Musique]
nous avons voulu améliorer le statut des
mers et notamment le régime indemnitaire
j'ai pu voir toutes les difficultés pour
exercer mon mandat d'élu local des
admins été né ne couvrait pas par
exemple les déplacements sur
l'agglomération mont-saint-michel
normandie la loi engagement et proximité
permet de prendre en charge certains
frais comme la garde des enfants parfois
il est difficile de conjuguer sa vie
professionnelle et sa vie d'élu de faire
en sorte que l'on puisse être à la fois
jeunes parents et s'engager dans une vie
municipale
c'est toi elle permet de sécuriser la
transition entre le dif et le compte
personnel de formation et c'est vrai que
ça sécurise et encourage les élus à
pouvoir se former après l'élection
[Musique]
ce que nous avons voulu faire parce que
nous sommes à 80 % à l'origine de cette
loi c'est renforcer la place de la
commune dans la communauté de communes
le maire est enfin remis au coeur de le
pc souvent dans les petites communes le
seul représentant à l'agglo c'est le
maire et du coup avec cette loi les élus
communaux ont la possibilité de
participer aux commissions
ça permet de soulager le maire c'est un
partage des compétences et c'est très
enrichissant que senna joue un rôle
essentiel à rolle aussi vertueux pour
que soit entendue
l'expression le malaise des élus de nos
territoires et le gouvernement ne
pouvait pas passer à côté de ces mesures
[Musique]